yes thank you so much Andre thank you
very much for being such a splendid host
thank you for the evenin yesterday with
the concert and today this library this
is a historic moment for Croatia because
it's a very first time that Croatia is
taking the EU presidency and it comes at
a very special moment for the new
Commission because you are the
presidency of our first 100 days so our
success also depends on your success and
thank you very much for the excellent
talks we've had over the last weeks but
also today indeed we have been
discussing the European Green Deal we
are aware of the fact that it is urgent
to move forward we have a very ambitious
goal to be climate neutral in 2050 if we
want to achieve that goal we have to be
active now and go forward with the
necessary legislation so within this
mandate it will be crucial to put in
place the necessary measures to reach
our very ambitious goal 2030 and 2050
and we are convinced that the European
Green Deal will be the new growth
strategy for the European Union it is
about investment it is about innovation
it is about new technologies and if the
world is following and the lining with
the Paris climate agreement and with our
ambitious goals then I want the European
Union to be a role model to be the
exporter of knowledge and new
technologies and to be the one who is
the front-runner in these topics for
that we will have to invest a lot and
therefore in the coming days we will
make proposals for the sustainable
Europe and vestment plan which is
basically the European Green Deal
investment plan and we will make
proposals for the just transition
mechanism to provide support for the
regions that have to step up the most I
know that you very much agree with these
goals thank you very much for the
support indeed we have been discussing
the MFF because for not only the
European Green Deal but many other
topics too we need an appropriate
funding so this presidency will be
crucial that we get the support in the
MFF for our ambitions and at the same
time support a greater convergence
between our respective Member States I
count on Croatia to help build this
consensus on our budget the third topic
we had is as you called it an
influential Europe we couldn't agree
more with that headline your presidency
will lead to the preparations on our
strategy with Africa in this presidency
will will have the college to college
meeting with Africa and the preparation
for the EU Africa summit we count on you
to build consensus in Council on some
important trade agreements we do have
and the next month will of course be
particularly crucial for a relationship
with the Balkans you introduced rightly
so the topic we know that we can count
on Croatia and that we have a very
strong supporter on our side the Zagreb
summit will be a potential milestone in
this process for that we have still to
do a lot of work we will be working on
the methodology and put forward for the
enlargement process the proposal for the
methodology early this year just to
reflect how we can improve the accession
process but I am deeply convinced that
they should not keep us from taking on
the
talks with North Macedonia and Albania
we ask them to do a lot they fulfilled
the criteria so now we do have to
deliver and to keep our promises with
this I am able to tell you talking about
standing at the side of Western Balkans
went that the European Union is happy to
announce that the donors conference for
Albania will be on the 17th of February
it's the donors conference following the
horrible earthquake in Albania and we
want to help Albania in its
reconstruction so this will take place
on the 17th of February last but not
least we have been briefly discussing
brexit I was on Wednesday in London to
meet Prime Minister Perce Johnson it is
important that it is a very clear
message from our sides we want to stay
good friends good neighbors and partners
it is the story of old friends and new
beginnings and we have to find a good
balance between divergence and being
close to the single market we both agree
that the European Union and the United
Kingdom share common values we have many
interests in coming and it was very good
to hear again that it is very clear that
we will have a very close cooperation on
the global stage when it comes to topics
like for example climate change the
United Kingdom is as dedicated as the
European Union and that topic or for
example security but of course we've
been very clear on the second topic to
which is access to the single market
there is a difference of being a member
state or not and there are trade-offs
between regulatory divergences on the
one side and a
says to the single market this room has
now to be explored in the coming
negotiations in June we will take stock
of this the progress and this will be in
an essential milestone falling under the
creation of presidency - so I'm glad
that I can count on your energy and your
dedication and Ray thank you very much
Allah president era become easier asada
Steven aredo Sepideh Nima ever polished
no profit and Tobias cars are developed
my name is Ahmad as a microphone Vanessa